sorority erosion
[Music]
boom a lower here - generally funded by
John Niner
hey everybody its charlie new dragon
ball trailer we got to break it down I
know there's a bunch of rumors about
different forms that they take there's a
big Gogeta rumor it seems like the end
of the trailer is implying that we'll
break it down shot by shot but this
animation is looking fantastic this is
way more polished than the previous
trailers that they've dropped if you're
brand new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
just getting started with Dragonball
stuff the movie isn't dropping until
December in Japan middle of January most
other places but be sure to check the
movie listings in your home country
because it's not the exact same day
every single place in the world love the
way that bro Lee calls vegeta out
veggietones it screams as he's going
after him after they've already powered
up through a couple different forums so
the way they cut the fights up is a
little jarring so obviously is probably
a linear progression of them just
powering through forms and just finding
out that bro Lee just keeps going like
there's no end to how powerful he gets
they cut it with those different cards
saying it's time for a new story of the
Saiyan warrior race told through combat
is almost like they're retelling the
complete story of the sands in a single
movie because you keep flashing back to
a young version of Frieza destroying
planet Vegeta I know a lot of people
have commented that in the original
Dragon Ball Z Battle of the Gods movie
they actually told a story that beerus
was responsible for Frieza
destroying planet Vegeta at the
beginning of the Dragon Ball super run
there were a couple beerus scenes that
made it a little confusing as to whether
or not that original story was still
canon or not so we'll just see what the
movie has to say about beerus as
potential involvement in what Frieza did
destroying planet Vegeta but that's why
you open up immediately with Goku going
super saiyan blue in that crazy
explosion so that's probably after he's
already fought him in regular super
saiyan mode you see him later at the
trailer flying it Broly in Broly just
laying him out that's probably what
leads him to go Super Saiyan blue but
the first veggie test shot that you get
is of him in super saiyan god mode
getting laid out by bro lee then you see
him react you get a flashback shot of
young Frieza calling in the shot on
their homeworld it blowing up and then
sort of juxtaposing their different
stories I like the way they make it seem
like it's destiny that they all have to
fight I know there's a lot of
questions about how old they are because
in the original version of the story all
the characters aren't the exact same age
like this version of Goku leaving the
planet is a little bit older than he was
in the original story you get the
flash-forward to when they first start
fighting and you see brawl is standing
up on the mountaintop and Goku saying I
think it's time that we fought you see
Broly wearing his control collar they
did confirm that that's a thing during
the movie because when Perry gues finds
Broly initially as a small child
he's so uncontrollably powerful the
reason for the control collar seems like
it's more just to give him a normal
liveable life otherwise his power would
be too much for him to handle I love the
shot of veggie to smirking at Broly this
may be when they first start fighting
whether or not bro Lee finds out who he
is immediately or after they've already
started powering up through their fight
because it doesn't look like there's a
whole lot of words that are exchanged
before they start throwing down
it looks like bro Lee fires that shot
right out of his mouth before he's even
powered up to super saiyan mode I'm
guessing that bro Lee does have a lot of
the similar forms that Goku and Vegeta
have just they're using the green energy
to distinguish him on-screen the way
they use color is great but usually you
associate that green color with
legendary super saiyan mode but the
energy that bro Lee gives off is the
same throughout most of the trailer the
only way you know which different form
he's in is by the color of his hair it's
not really true his hair turns green and
his shirt gets all ripped off do you
know he's gone legendary Super Saiyan
the funny thing about this scene is
vegetto goes super saiyan god mode
punches him right in the face and Broly
eats it like it's no big deal the
reaction on vegeto's face is priceless
you see an explosion in the sky from one
of those corresponding fights he grabs
Goku who's already gone Super Saiyan God
and just slides him along this glacier
here like it's no big deal it sounds
like it's bro Lee who's the one saying
you dare push me to these links do you
just implying as he's powering up
through forms that it's never going to
end like he's eventually going to push
himself past the ultimate limit which as
they imply in this movie is a legendary
Super Saiyan even though we saw ultra
instinct during Dragon Ball super most
of the comments that the production crew
have talked about when talking about
ultra instinct imply that they're not
going to do it during this movie you
finally see gold Frieza enter the fight
this could happen a little bit later you
don't really see him during many of
these other fights like initially it
just seems like Goku and Vegeta fighting
him
we know a little bit about freezes
backstory because you see all the sands
with King cold back when he was young
before he destroyed the planet so I've
already explained a little bit about the
plot of how Broly winds up in the
freezer for us because he's stranded on
an alien planet while they're busy
destroying planet Vegeta so he only
comes to it later and doesn't know
anything about what Frieza has done you
get a new shot of the Dragon Balls
Shenron it'll be interesting to see what
the wish is during this because usually
the big twist is is when there's this
insurmountable fight is that someone
sacrifices their life then they get
brought back to life through a Dragon
Ball wish we get a new shot of piccolo a
beerus of Wiese we get a couple of new
full frontal shots of Goku and Super
Saiyan God form the dialogue sounds like
Goku talking to broli
you ain't a bad guy I can tell this is
them trying to humanize Broly a little
bit more instead of just being the green
Hulk rage monster that he was during the
original bro Lee movies this way they
flashed the card after it says a new
tale as and we're doing a slightly
different story this shot is of lemo
inch Eli's saying he's not biting
because he wants to fight they're
probably talking about bro Lee hard to
tell which planet they're on when this
is happening this could be happening on
planet earth in the arctic area where
the rest of this battle is or this could
be earlier in the timeline when they
first find bro Lee because these are the
two characters in the freezer force that
find bro Lee and Parris on the alien
planet and bring them to Frieza and
induct them into the freezer force as we
get through the last part of the trailer
things start to escalate Goku has gone
into super saiyan blue mode bro Lee is
in full Super Saiyan mode he's got the
yellow hair which is why I'm thinking
this is supposed to be his version of
Super Saiyan you get that very teaser a
line of dialogue you've still got even
more you see burly erupt with all these
different explosions going on around him
and this green energy coming off this
might be while he's powering up to
legendary super saiyan because it seems
like they're intercutting this with an
earlier part of the fight where they're
both in super saiyan blue mode fighting
Broly then this is probably my favorite
shot from the trailer when videos like
damn it all and they both go at the same
time as Super Saiyan blue mode so
obviously they're using slightly
different colors of energy I love the
yellow and blue here together but for
those of you that are expecting Gogeta
during the movie and there are a couple
of bits of evidence that they might
include it this moment seems like it's
building towards Okochi diffusion as in
like they both powerup to their
different forms Super Saiyan God Mode
Super Saiyan blue mode isn't quite
enough to take Broly down because he
keeps powering up as well you finally
have them both working together in one
of their most powerful forms that might
not still be enough to scratch Broly so
maybe they go fusion and I think you
know the big reaction that a lot of fans
are hoping for is that in Gogeta form
they still get their ass handed to them
by burly it's still not enough
because canon or not canon they have
never been defeated
while in Gogeta form so would just be a
really cool moment if they go fusion and
Broly still kicks there bud but then
either after they blast him or after
this earlier moment here where you see
him erupt in green energy Burleigh goes
full legendary super saiyan and they end
the trailers he flies into frame
everybody let me know in the comments
what your favorite moment from the
trailer and do you actually think that
they go Gogeta during the movie leave
all your requests for Dragon Ball videos
in the comments click here to rewatch
the other movie trailers and click here
for that brand new Captain Marvel teaser
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]